-I thought I'd share
some of my favorite
#textfail stories from you guys.
Here we go.
This first one's
from @memersvg.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
This one's from @lisalou9399.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Thanks a lot, Mom.
-Wow.
-This one's from @shoholajc.
He says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's not worth it.
Not even worth getting mad at.
-Didn't say "text me."
Said "send me."
-This one's
from @sdbalasundaram.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Late yate.
-Late yate.
-This one is from
@HannahEStrother.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
That's nice.
Appreciate that.
[ Chuckles ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, this one's good. This one's
from @hannah pellicer.
She says...
It says...
♪ As soon as you get to Alabama,
uh ♪
♪ Uh, as soon
as you get to Alabama, uh ♪
♪ As soon as
you get to Alabama, uh ♪
you get to Alabama, huh ♪
♪ As soon as
you get to Alabama, uh ♪
♪ Go see Bananarama, mm ♪
[ Laughter and applause ]
Go see Bananarama when I get...?
Are they on tour?
-Rappers love Bananarama.
-They're on tour, yeah.
This one's from @LindsaySwink.
She says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Oh, I didn't mean --
Just meet by the bathroom.
-Not in the bathroom.
Oh.
-This last one is from
the one and only Sheryl Crow.
-Oh.
-She played the game.
[ Cheers and applause ]
We love Sheryl Crow.
Thank you for playing.
Sheryl, we love you.
Got a new record out,
by the way.
Sheryl says...
Look at this, it says...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Don't call me that, Mom.
There you have it.
Those are
our "Tonight Show" hashtags.
To check out
more of our favorites,
go to tonightshow.com/hashtags.